one thing that I am trying to get at in
the books a political aspect if you
would is to kind of show that this stuff
is hard I I mean I think an awful lot of
fantasy and and even some great fantasy
falls into the mistake of assuming that
the good man will be a good king that is
all that is necessary is to be like a
decent human being and then when you're
king of course everything will go
swimmingly and you know you even toki
and you know who is the I think my
respect for toki and no second to none
and all modern fantasy flows from
Tolkien but there's an unspoken
assumption in his books there that you
know Return of the King
Aragorn is the king now everything will
be will be hunky-dory you know the land
will prosper and it'll be wonderful and
the crops will be good and there will be
justice for all and the enemies will be
defeated and you know you never you
never actually get into the nitty-gritty
of Aragorn ruling and you know what what
his tax policy and how does he feel
about crop rotation and you know where
how does he handle land disputes between
two Nobles both of whom think that they
should have this particular village so
they take turns burning it down in order
to establish this claim the this is the
hard parts of ruling and be it in the
Middle Ages or now and of course it's
not enough to be a good man to be an
effective ruler and it never has been
you know if it has been you know Jimmy
Carter would be the greatest president
of the 20th century I mean he's clearly
I think the best human being to be
president in my lifetime but he was not
a particularly effective president for
all his his decency and his humanity and
his compassion when his undoubted
intelligence I mean the man was a
nuclear engineer and then in a navy but
nonetheless he failed at it and I've
been there were some examples of
medieval kings in in history who were
terrible human beings but they were
nonetheless very good Kings for their
country so it's complicated and it's
hard
and I wanted to show not just with it
with the women but you know you see in
my books repeated examples of both Kings
and and the hand of the King - Prime
Minister if you would trying to rule and
and whether it be Ned Stark or Tyrion
Lannister or Tywin Lannister or you know
Daenerys Targaryen in the latest book
Cersei Lannister in the in the book
before that and trying to deal with some
of the real challenges that affect
anyone trying to rule the Seven Kingdoms
or even the city like marine and it's
hard you know we can all read these
books or look at history and say oh
so-and-so was stupid that made a lot of
mistakes look at all these stupid
mistakes they make but these kind of
mistakes are always much more apparent
in hindsight than when you're actually
kind of faced with the decision about my
god what what would I do in this
situation how do I resolve the thing do
I do the moral thing but what about the
political consequences of the moral
thing do I do the the pragmatic cynical
thing and just kind of screw the people
who are screwed but it I mean it's hard
and I want to get to want to get to all
of that and be it a male ruler or a
woman woman's ruler